what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are jumping into our first
story of Marvel legacy which you know is
appropriate that it's amazing spider-man
spider-man do you know it's interesting
to me when it comes to comic books
because I mean honestly I consider
spider-man to be like the third most
popular superhero in existence you know
who's you know basically falls behind
like Superman is number one and Batman
is number two but spider-man is like the
face of Marvel and so it's so
interesting because it's like the
character from Marvel Comics that
everybody knows it's really kind of wild
here but there is a lot of history here
there is a lot of stuff that goes into
this in terms of the spider-man legacy
things like that now as I've always
stated I am NOT the expert on spider-man
so with common pop knows probably more
about comics and I'll ever know but he
certainly knows more about spider-man
that I'll ever know so it's kind of
crazy but with this whole thing it is
really interesting because this really
comes as the aftermath to secret Empire
remember when it comes to Marvel legacy
it's sort of like Marvel's DC rebirth in
a lot of different ways you had the
Marvel Legacy one-shot you had the
generations tie-ins and all the
generations tie-ins were designed to do
is basically tell us what happened in
secret Empire when Captain America wiped
everybody away from existence using the
Cosmic Cube the generation stories is
what they were doing Marvel legacy
number one is basically what sets
everything in motion in terms of the
Marvel legacy line of stories and so
this basically comes out of secret
Empire and all the things that took
place from all-new all-different marvel
up until this point now for the
character of Mockingbird for the
character of Bobby Moore's essentially
what happened with her she was just a
longtime member of the Marvel community
who just kind of had minor roles here in
there she was part of the Avengers for a
little while she was a molten shield and
that was really about it
I think one of the biggest moments with
her character came an all-new
all-different amazing spider-man part of
it was because of the fact that she and
Peter Parker worked together so often
but also because of the fact that she
was introduced or at least kind of
brought in as a new love interest for
Peter Parker but what did he keep in
mind and even one of the things is
talked about here is that he's basically
just kind of crashing with her he's
basically hanging out with her you know
just because of the fact they doesn't
really have a home of his own and this
all comes out of secret Empire the
collapse of Parker Industries now for
those of you guys who are getting into
Marvel legacy or really ending a moment
for the very first time by way of Marvel
legacy Parker Industries was basically a
concept that was launched by Doctor
Octopus when he took over the body of
Peter Parker and again that's all in the
amazing spider-man playlist sure
go back and watch it all but the whole
idea here was that there was basically a
point where Doctor Octopus was dying and
in order to keep himself alive he had
devised a sort of device of sorts that
would allow him to basically take over
the mind of Peter Parker now over the
course of the Amazing Spiderman line of
stories running up to life suicide run
and different things like that it was
essentially Doctor Octopus finally
taking over the body of Peter and his
totality or at least that seemed to be
the case
Peter was residing in the background but
he didn't really have any control
anymore
one of the things that Doctor Octopus
had done was basically begin the process
of sort of building up this massive
legacy in the mind of Doctor Octopus he
was going to stay in the body of Peter
Parker forever until you know the body
of Peter Parker died and so in order to
ensure that he made the most of the
experience
he began basically putting his mind to
task and developing a litany of
different things now a lot of this was
just various technological gadgets that
would make his life easier spider-man
but the biggest part of it was Parker
industries and Parker industries you
know eventually just kind of became this
massive conglomerate now the problem
with this is we don't really know how we
basically had Parker industries being
formed by Doctor Octopus it was a very
fledgling thing and then we skipped
ahead eight months and suddenly it was
this massive conglomerate and there was
no real explanation in terms of how it
got there but the idea was that with
Peter Parker getting his body back he
was basically running Parker Industries
as the CEO the problem with this was
that with Doctor Octopus having been
defeated having been cast out of Peters
body
he basically resigned himself to the
body of a machine kind of lying in wait
waiting for his chance to strike again
and so what ended up happening is during
all-new all-different amazing spider-man
running up to his story called clone
conspiracy dr. octopus remained in the
background
and because clone conspiracy was
basically a story that dealt with the
return of Ben Riley who was basically
cloning all these different people who
had died over the course of Peters life
Doctor Octopus created a new body for
himself and when he did he returned as
superior spider-man and so what ended up
happening is this went directly into
secret Empire and it basically led to
Doctor Octopus and Peter Parker fighting
Peter Parker realizing there was no way
to defeat Doctor Octopus or at least
keep Parker Industries with the
exception of hitting a doomsday button
and so what he basically did was destroy
Parker industries he basically implanted
a sort of virus that went out to all the
wetware technology they had everything
that everybody owned phones tablets and
basically just destroyed everything and
so Parker industries stock just
absolutely crumbled the company was
virtually worthless and this left Peter
Parker back where he
before it all started essentially being
broke again and so what this story is
designed to do is sort of bring us back
to that familiarity bring us back to the
Peter Parker that we remember and
basically take him back to the guy who's
barely making ends meet a lot of people
wanted to see Peter as the struggling
kid that was just kind of a mainstay of
his character you know Peter Parker was
spider-man he'd go out he'd saved the
day he was one of the smartest men on
the planet but when the mask came off
and the costume went to the closet he
was a guy who was barely able to pay
rent
it really humanized his character in a
lot of ways and so bringing it back to
these things basically having him in a
situation where Bobby Morris has a
refrigerator full of food and all of it
says if this is not Peter Parker's you
cannot eat any of this it's pretty
intriguing now from here we switch over
to Harry Osborn and one thing to keep in
mind as Harry Osborn has a very long
very tenuous and a lot of a lot of ways
very tangled history and Marvel of
course as the son of Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin Harry Osborn became the
Green Goblin
somewhere along the line but his path
has largely been one of redemption and
Marvel in recent years in a sense that
he's basically trying to go back to
being a good guy he's basically returned
to being one of Peter Parker's closest
friends and so in this instance what
he's actually done is gotten back
together with a girl named Liz Allen but
Liz Allen was basically a longtime
member of the spider-man family and when
I see the spider-man family I'm
referring to people who were there at
the beginning of the spider-man comics
Gwen Stacy Mary Jane Watson Harry Osborn
Norman Osborn people who have been
around there since the beginning who
have been in Marvel Comics you know for
almost 60 years 70 years that have all
been a part of this spider-man mythos
the roles have changed but at the end of
the day they're still there this whole
idea with Harry is that he's basically
operating as the kind of guy who is
essentially picking up the pieces where
Peter Parker was a former CEO and where
he's basically just sort of collapsed
into himself Harry Osborn is the one
that's doing what Peter Parker should be
doing in the sense that Harry Osborn's
basically organizing for the sale of
various assets of Parker industries in
an effort to basically satisfy the
various lawsuits that have been filed
against him but the other half of this
is that with Peter it's dealing more
with the public backlash as opposed to
anything else because of the fact that
he used to work at the Daily Bugle and
because Robbie Robertson was one of the
long-standing members who is always in
Peters corner when this situation
unfolds Peter's reading all these
articles from the Daily Bugle well
they're basically lambaste him calling
him a failures and he's a guy that just
collapsed in on himself for him it's
almost a personal violation considering
that him and
robertson were friends for so long but
what did he keep in mind is that with
Robbie Robertson he was always the
middle of the ground guy it was always
let's tell the story with the facts
let's not put a slant on it and so
because of this with Peter Parker's
showing up and saying why are you
creating a why are you writing all these
articles about me Robbie Robertson's
response is because it's true because
you were a guy who is in no position to
run a multi-billion dollar industry you
didn't go to college and major in
business management it was just kind of
given to you and you did what almost
anybody does when they get something
they don't earn they squander it in its
entirety and so because of this Peters
response and that's kind of the
interesting thing Peter's response
behind the scenes is he was doing
everything that was right and that's why
the story are so cool because it gives
us these sort of different perspectives
in terms of how all this unfolds in
Peters mind
he destroyed Parker industries in order
to keep him from falling into the hands
of dr. octopus who would have done God
knows what with it with Robbie Robertson
all he sees is the front side Peter
Parker was running a corporation Peter
Parker wasn't ready for it Peter Parker
ran into the ground and a story and so
it's kind of interesting you know with
regards to these two diametrically
opposed views on the same thing coming
from two different perspectives but the
way to Peter basically hits home with
Robbie Robertson and the idea that he
could go back to work at the Daily Bugle
is when one of their guys is going
through their whole science section and
basically typing up an article that the
average person wouldn't even begin to be
able to understand Peter's response is
no no here's what you have to do here's
what you have to say and here's the way
that you do it in an easy-to-understand
way Robbie Robertson immediately picks
that up and it just kind of occurs to
him this is the job for Peter Parker and
so at this point we kind of continue the
idea of this atham aftermath Peter
Parker walking to the streets Peter
Parker basically being mobbed by people
who were angry and rightfully so because
Parker Industries employed millions of
people not only that there were
countless there were millions and
millions of other people who used you
know Parker industries products on
products now some of this was people who
basically had stock in the company who
lost a lot of money when it went under
and so in light of this these people who
are freaking out are coming from
different perspectives from something
for other people if something as small
is the idea that all their wedding
photos were basically backed up to the
parker industries cloud and they're all
gone now moments in time that they will
never get back are gone forever
so the collapse of Parker industries
impacts the general public in a variety
of
ways financially emotionally with
regards to their own personal histories
different things like that
it's a pretty big deal and it's pretty
massive and so in order to cheer him up
what is up happening his body Morris
actually grabs on and says let's just go
out on the town let's just go out and
have some fun and let's just kind of be
superheroes for the night and this is
cool this is really interesting it's one
of the things that I like about this
when you read or when you think about
amazing spider-man legacy your first
thought is okay we're gonna jump right
into it we're gonna start a story
there's gonna be all these things going
on a Peter Parker is gonna be spider-man
but that was one of the big mistakes of
like all-new all-different marvel it was
immediately jumping in and then just
setting everything up for some great big
huge story jumping into the middle of a
story when it comes to characters people
need to be eased in especially with
somebody like spider-man who is wildly
popular but has such a convoluted
history and that's why this is cool it's
getting back to familiarity it's getting
back to that history that people are so
familiar with that's why I would say
amazing spider-man legacy is probably a
shot in the nostalgia for a lot of
people who have been reading spider-man
for a very very long time because
they're seeing all these callbacks of
stories that they read 20 years ago 25
years ago maybe even 30 years ago if
they're old enough to have been reading
that long but the other half of this is
the public perception of spider-man
versus Peter Parker where a lot of
people associate spider-man with Peter
Parker because of the fact that under
Parker industries spider-man was the
bodyguard of Peter people also recognize
that he is a hero and it's one of those
things where they just kind of give him
a pass where the anger is there where
the irritation is there spider-man
swinging in saving the day he's doing
what he's always done and that's why
it's cool again they'll return to this
whole familiar thing and so following
this we basically pick up in the
aftermath which is to say Peter
basically sitting down alongside Norman
Osborn the various people who have filed
lawsuits against him people who were
employees people who bought Parker
industries products and essentially
issuing an apology the crazy thing about
this is that an apology from a former
CEO who in the public eye taint the
company and cost people boatloads of
money and personal you know personal
items personal backups
does little to cancel their emotions to
consult their anger and their irritation
and so while Peter Parker is just like
them just the average person trying to
make their way in the world at the end
of the day they're angry and they want
to vent that anger at someone rightfully
so or unrightfully so but regardless of
the circumstance you know what Peter
Parker walks out of this meeting there's
pink you know people who are picketing
people who are protesting the whole yard
he just really kind of bails out he just
really sort of takes off now at this
point we switch over to a guy named
Clayton cold late Nicole was basically a
guy who was just a super genius but the
funny thing about this is that where he
was and you know a villain that kind of
appeared periodically in the realm of
Marvel Comics and the spider-man stories
during the events of civil war - when
you had the inhuman Ulysses who had
these glimpses of the future his idea
was basically he saw a future where
Clayton Cole would attack Peter Parker
wasn't the biggest thing in the world it
wasn't a world shattering event the
Peter Parker realizing this was the case
decided to give Clayton Cola second
chance see if he could steer him away
from this path when he becomes a villain
not by locking him out but by giving him
a chance to express his creative juices
in terms of you know his scientific
prowess the problem with this is that
with the collapse of Parker industries
everything Parker industries owned as
well you know including the Baxter
building where they took up residence is
being liquidated as being sold and so in
the mind of Clayton he's basically
organizing this massive attempt to break
into the Baxter building steal
everything that belongs to them and then
sell it which is not necessarily wrong
now under the contract that you know
Clinton Cole signed working for Parker
industries anything he creates is the
property of the company so technically
speaking the company's selling off his
own assets but the company was made
successful by the people who built it
and so if you're Clayton Cole and you're
sitting down and you realized everything
Parker industries owns is being sold off
including the things that you created
while you didn't you weren't responsible
for the destruction of Parker industries
at the end of the day the things you
created the things that are part of who
you are your heart and soul so to speak
it's just kind of being sold off to the
highest bidder because the person who
owned the company screwed up so again a
lot of personal emotions in this because
this is also the Baxter building Johnny
Storm steps in remember following the
events of seeker wars and the launch of
all-new all-different marvel Susan storm
Reed Richards Franklin Richards the
Larry Richards the Fantastic Four at
least half the team as we knew them was
basically gone there were nowhere to be
found
the idea of Peter Parker as you know
under Parker Industries buying the
Baxter building was to basically erect a
statue within the building of the
Fantastic Four to simply say no one will
be able to buy this building now so when
the Fantastic Four come back I'll just
give it to them you know it'll be a way
to basically have a keepsake for the
team Johnny Storm loved this idea but
now the tables have turned the worst
fears of Johnny Storm are beginning to
come true when the parker industries
assets are being liquidated the
buildings being sold to some condo guy
basically just gonna put a whole bunch
of high-rise condos in there it pisses
off Johnny storm because his family
legacy is being so lost so again the
aftermath personal conflicts and so what
this does is it basically leads to Harry
Osborn pointing out the fact the Clayton
coal is breaking you know they're gonna
just steal all the stuff which is kind
of interesting because what they end up
doing is basically activating a device
but has the ability to wipe out a city
block if it reaches full charge so
basically it kind of brings together
Johnny storm and Clayton coal to
spider-man in order to essentially keep
this from happening some of the
criminals are basically wrapped up
clayton cole ends up making his escape
at the end of it all but again this is
all just kind of fall out this is all
aftermath Harry Osborn gets tired of
this game he basically walks what we end
up having is Robbie Robertson offering
Peter Parker a job but not as a
photographer is a return to familiarity
but is also some new things and that's
the nature of doing these sort of soft
reboots remember while whatever does
hard reboots mother never resets
everything back to square one in this
scenario this soft reboot of sorts this
kind of revitalization reshuffling
setting everything back to rights
it does have Peter Parker going back to
his job as a Daily Bugle but really for
a guy who ran a company who helped to
develop some of these extremely advanced
devices having a be a photographer would
almost seem like a waste but having him
work in the Science Division basically
publishing articles is actually pretty
cool so of course once he takes this job
he ends up talking about Morris who's
basically landed a job in a place called
humanity grow box now as far as I'm
aware he man attacked and Xander's in
these are new characters that have
basically been thrown in what is up
happening here is that with you know
Peter calling Bobby Morris and her
basically telling him look I have the
ability to get you an interview with the
hottest tech company that's creating
legitimate artificial intelligence is
interesting because once Peter Parker
grabs his crew and they head to humanity
what Peter Parker ends up realizing is
that all these robots that basically are
functioning under the mantle of AI are
all using brain patterns and so it's
intriguing because repeaters kind of
like alright were these brain patterns
coming from and of course once one of
the guys tries to open it up his spider
sense kicks off Peter tries to hold the
thing together and when they're
basically kicked out of the facility
Peter and Bobby Moore's visit it later
on that night in the middle of
investigating this whole thing all these
robots begin to start activating only
for Xander's in to basically make his
presence known and to say if you break
these things open not only will you
destroy the entire company that's been
built here everything that we've
established but you're also going to
unleash a super villain that neither of
you could really hope to have
on your own and so once they start going
through and basically breaking out all
these silicon matrices they basically
serve the purpose is the brain of sorts
for these robots what we end up finding
out here is that inside and all these
robots is a character named quicksand
now a little bit of history here when it
comes to the character of quicksand she
appeared back in Thor issue number 392 I
want to say that's the case I'm fuzzy on
this I am NOT a hundred percent sure
this is the case anyway she's been
around for a really long time but
quicksand is basically a catch where we
don't really know who she is but she's
basically an answer to Sandman to
William Baker who appeared in amazing
spider-man number four Sal overcome a
pop tell me if I'm wrong or not but the
whole idea behind this is that with
Sandman kind of standing as one of the
really popular villains of the
spider-man landscape and because a lot
of spider-man's ROK's galleries so
iconic because Thor was not the highest
selling title that Marvel had at the
time Marvel says I are really for a lot
of people who were not the x-men or
spider-man their idea was to grab a lot
of the villains who existed in relation
to those characters kind of rework them
and then throw them into other
characters books and then basically give
us those characters in that form so for
the character of quicksand she's not
really composed of sand she basically
kind of manipulates particles or at
least is able to transform her body into
something that's akin to sand but
regardless of the scenario the cool
thing about this is that she was
basically grabbed by Xander's in and
essentially thrown into all these
different devices all that you know all
these different robots and it kind of
works because she's essentially a hive
mind composed of all these different you
know molecular particles Atkin descent
and so because of this what it means is
she could basically be broken down into
little pieces and each one is conscious
in and of itself but it's all part of a
hive mind she was basically enslaved by
Xander's in and forced to be the AI that
would allow all these robots to function
and do their own thing now of course
again not a great big huge thing and we
know this because of the fact that where
she goes to attack you know Sanders in
spider-man steps in says no you can't go
around attacking people like that you
got to let him go do this for me we'll
call it even and so as a result she
basically says okay fine I owe you this
she ends up taking off and Xander's an
basically bails out as well but again
that's the cool thing about all this
it's not designed to set the stage for
these great big huge events it's
basically designed to sort of give us a
return to familiarity for the character
of spider-man and so with this story
once everything winds down the article
this written based on humanity
follow the company what it was that they
were really doing behind the scenes in
terms of what they were capable of how
their whole AI works with regards to
quicksand the whole nine yards the funny
thing about this is that this is
business as usual you know it's not some
grand great big huge thing and everybody
passed Peter on the back says good job
man take the next couple months off
you've earned it instead it's what do
you have for me next week it's back to
the way things always work its back to
Peter Parker back to business back to
the character that we're familiar with
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]